u.s president donald trump has dismissed
a new york times report detailing
years of tax avoidance according to the
report
trump paid no federal income tax in 10
of the last 15 years
the report says he was able to cut his
tax bill by claiming heavy losses
across his business empire thereby
losing more money than he made and
casting doubt on his image
as a successful businessman
we've heard this line of defense from
the president before that's fake news
it's totally fakeness made up fake
but with less than 24 hours until the
presidential debate
the damage may have already been done
new tax revelations published by the new
york times
are likely to give democratic rival joe
biden
fresh ammunition at the traditional
event responsibility
donald trump was reported to have paid
just 750 dollars
in federal income taxes in 2016 the year
he won the presidency
and in 2017 his first year in office
he paid no income taxes whatsoever in 10
of previous 15 years
that's because he reported losing more
money than he made
according to the times he's also
reported to be personally responsible
for loans and other debts totaling more
than 420 million dollars
they are damaging claims for a man who
derives some of his support from blue
collar workers
through his self-promoted image as a
successful businessman
the president denies the details in the
new york times report
well first of all i paid a lot and i
paid a lot of state income taxes too
uh the new york state charges a lot and
i paid a lot of money at state
uh it'll all be revealed it's going to
come out
but after the auditors after the i'm
being
they're doing their assessment we've
been negotiating for
a long time things get settled like in
the irs but right now when you're under
audit
you don't do it you don't do that so
we're under audit
but the story is a total fake but his
opponents have already begun to hit back
trump has long avoided making his tax
returns public
and he's the only u.s president since
the 1970s to do so
as the november election looms voters
may demand more answers about the
president's financial responsibilities
now let's bring in dws peter golidar
from our u.s
reporter team peter what exactly does
this
article about donald trump's tax return
tell us right so the new york times
obtained
trump's tax return data extending back
more than two decades it both shows
trump's own tax records but also those
of his
more than 100 organizations that are
linked to his business
um it essentially showed that he has
lost more money than he's made
that he really to some extent has been
gaming the tax system with
massive write-offs such as you know
spending more than seventy thousand
dollars on on his hair stylist
um and all of that taken together
allowed him to pay
close to no income taxes in 10 of the
previous
15 years and in 2016 2017
while he was president he paid just 750
dollars
that is more than 11 000
less than the average tax income pair in
the us
um joe biden and his wife the democratic
challenger
paid more than 3.7 million in 2017 so
quite the difference there um it also
showed that trump really is facing
a uh cash crunch for his businesses
within the next four years we have
uh we're looking at more than 300
millions
worth of loans coming due all of which
trump has personally guaranteed so this
really puts
you know lenders in the position where
they may have to foreclose on a sitting
precedent
is this a bombshell it sounds like it
but is this really a bombshell or is it
not
well it certainly flies squarely in the
face of this brand that trump has spent
all these years building for himself
right as a successful businessman as a
as a very skilled deal maker it also
confirms a lot of the rumors and the
reporting that we actually have been
seeing for the past couple years that he
may not have been
you know as successful and wealthy as he
claimed i mean this is a guy who after
all filed for bankruptcy more than
or six times um it also may help explain
why trump has been very reluctant to
divest himself
from his uh persons businesses while
he's also really encouraged
the use of his personal properties
including his his
hotels and golf courses he's built the
government hundreds of thousands of
dollars for the use of those properties
including
the secret service for protecting trump
while he was out playing golf
um it doesn't smell it doesn't smell
right does it it what
impact if any do you think this will
have on the elections
yeah again you know these allegations
really do go to the heart
of his appeal where especially if you
look at some of the key swing states and
in the rust belt
wisconsin pennsylvania michigan a lot of
these places
uh you know that have been struggling
financially for years
were looking to trump hoping that
because of his
business acumen that he would be able to
revive their economies
um you know democrats we've seen already
kind of give us a taste of their line of
attack we have an ad here you know
showing
you know trump as someone who is
self-serving who is really
only out to enrich himself and who can't
really relate to working class people
um there's one set of rules for for
trump and his administration
um but not for everyone else
and you know also really undermines
trump's promise as someone who
you know wanted to drain the swamp
people and yeah and all that and you
know
democrats right here you know the buy
and campaign selling stickers state i
paid more taxes than donald trump
so you know this is coming at a time
when a lot of americans really are
struggling financially because of the
pandemic
and you know some on the fence may
wonder you know why does the president
have to pay
you know less in taxes than i do
but ashley kind of hinted at there i
think with your question also you know
we've seen these attacks on trump before
they have not stuck um his support has
been solid and so
you know even in 2016 during the debates
he said you know i don't pay taxes
because i'm smart a lot of people bought
that argument then
and i wouldn't be surprised if a lot of
people will continue to point to that
and say you know
he is smart peter thank you very much
[Music]